the 70s in New York were one wild ride
from the avant-garde art of Andy Warhol
to the edgy sounds of punk rock it was a
crazy kinetic decade that redefined pop
culture and artists Duncan Hannah was in
the middle of it all his rollicking
Journal's 20th century boy notebooks on
the 70s are being published next week we
recently met up with Hannah at his
Brooklyn New York studio
Duncan Hannah was 19 when he landed in
New York in 1971 an art student from
Minneapolis in a city so alive he wrote
in his journals this place is a monster
so you just put anything in here that
was catching your fancy at the time yeah
I've always been a visual hoarder when
would you do this I had a good
discipline I guess I have a some kind of
Puritan work ethic where if I didn't I'd
feel guilty throughout the decade he
filled dozens of elaborate notebooks
which he titled and illustrated I'm rich
in my poverty he wrote in the prime of
life he paid the rent doing magazine
illustrations living for the nightlife
like one epic after party in 1974 after
a roxy music concert at the end of it
Andy Warhol said we're all going to the
82 club you want to come and I said sure
anyhow it was Bryan Ferry and David
Bowie and Andy and me you know in the
car yeah what are you thinking at that
moment
I was thinking wow my dream and the next
thing he remembers is waking up alone in
an abandoned Harlem apartment building
with no idea how you got there no in my
party clothes had a bowtie and and why
would I be on the fifth floor I mean
maybe the first floor but the fifth that
story seems to sort of symbolize the
high and the low of this yeah it went
from the most glamorous to the most
tawdry all in the space of 12 hours
Hannah became friends with Warhol I
brought Andy did CBGB's to see the
talking heads cuz I thought he'd liked
them and he
he thought they were really cute and he
said oh do you think they'd like to come
to lunch and I said yes I think they
probably would and he attracted the
interest of another prominent artist and
he spread his arms and said dolly is
here the extravagant surrealist Salvador
Dali and then he said to me you are
going to model as an angel for Dali and
I said sure and he said but wait do you
have hair in your chest and I said oh no
I don't and he said oh good dolly just
not paint angels with hair in their
chest he didn't end up modeling but he
did end up acting in underground films
like unmade beds Debbie Harry's in it
she's very good I was not very good did
you like being an actor no I appreciate
good acting and then I realized
appreciating good acting and executing
good acting they're two very different
things
deeper into the 70s the decade grew
darker I'm caught in the tempo he wrote
I'm compelled to live in downtown's
disordered mind young people we're out
early here this looked like it's getting
late
yes getting late is one way to put it
but I'm trying in his journals Hana
worried he could become another fatality
of bohemia 'he's wicked ways wouldn't
the brave option be to try to live a
positive life he wrote wouldn't that be
a rebellion so the young artist sobered
up his work was also an act of rebellion
hannah embraced figurative painting even
as the art world declared it dead
the critics didn't seem to know what no
no I mean they just assumed I was being
ironic and this was some kind of
critique of art history which it wasn't
it was a more of a love letter to art
history
since his first solo show in 1981 he's
had a hundred exhibitions his paintings
are in the permanent collection of the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and have been
featured on many book covers what's
going on here
well I don't know it's a bit of a
mystery isn't it one critic described an
ominous poise in his pictures of vintage
racing cars old worlds and obscure
European starlets I think it's the world
I thought I was going to grow up into in
the 50s kind of a fictional Europe it's
like an alternative universe it's Duncan
Hanna's world the one he first dreamed
of in his journals what impressed you in
your own journals well everything I
wanted actually came true I was
impressed by that it did come true these
journals are so much fun he's actually a
really good writer too deeply poetic
thoughts ya know we small out yeah and
and he took the time to somehow put it
all down and he survived yeah which is
impressive on both counts and mmm and a
reminder that we should all journal more
frequently it's important to have a
chronicle of your life and a
contemporary one and it really is it
really is a piece of history
20th century boy is the name of the book
great read great cover